[Applause]
you may have heard of the million dollar
Banksy painting that was shredded at
auction right after it's sold now art
experts think that it could be worth
nearly double but why how is the value
of any work of art determined will be
honest it seems a little bit arbitrary
and was this the destruction of a
valuable piece of art or the creation of
a new one
[Music]
on October 5th 2018 Sotheby's in London
auctioned off a framed girl with balloon
painting the Banksy piece was valued at
approximately two to three hundred
thousand pounds at the auction the
paintings sold for eight hundred sixty
thousand pounds plus Sotheby's
commission making the total an
impressive 1 million in 42,000 pounds
that's about 1.4 million dollars as the
hammer fell an alarm sounded from the
frame and the painting spontaneously
shredded after the option Banksy took to
Instagram to reveal that he himself had
built the shredder into the frame this
type of stunt is pretty typical Banksy
but apparently this one did not go
exactly as planned
nearly two weeks later bangs he posted a
second video showing that the shredder
had malfunctioned
he claimed that it was supposed to cut
through with the entire piece instead of
stopping halfway
[Music]
so what makes this such a historical
moment in the art world we asked
Danielle ROM the managing director of
New York fine art appraisers and senior
member of the American Society of
appraisers the stunts that banks he
pulled at the auction was brilliant in
both conception and execution the most
captivating thing about this story is
how easy it is to understand it has
become really this viral talking point
for everybody about the meaning of art
and the meaning of money in capitalism
and it's become such a larger issue than
just the painting itself being shredded
the piece has since been renamed love is
in the bin but how much is this piece
actually worth now there's been a lot of
talk about whether he actually destroyed
art or created it and I'm in the school
that he created it it was essentially
performance art in in execution and then
on top of that performance art it made a
new conceptual piece of art and even got
a new title love is in the bin is
definitely one of Banksy's most iconic
images at this point there's been a
tremendous amount of media coverage
about it that certainly self perpetuates
and makes it worth even more than it
would have been anyway
but it's burned in everybody's mind who
has seen that video the moment where it
shreds through the through the picture
frame is not going anywhere I would say
that if this was to go up for auction
again it would bring significantly more
than it did the first time possibly over
twice the amount and how is the value of
a piece determined Danielle told us that
art appraisers try to examine each piece
in person they look at the physical
condition to see how much it's worth
then they research the piece and
compared to similar works that have sold
recently in order to place a value on it
since the news broke art collectors have
flocked to art brokers asking whether or
not they should shred their own
authentic Banksy pieces
according to my art broker calm website
that resells Banksy artwork one person
even went through with it and shredded
an unsigned mint Banksy print worth
40,000 pounds hoping it would then be
worth double
however the destruction of the piece
allegedly reduced its value to only one
single pound if you own a Banksy print
my recommendation is not to shred it
Banksy as an artist has the right to
disavow any work that's been damaged
altered or mutilated beyond this
original attack so he can shred the work
and he can create a new work out of it
but someone else trying it at home is
not gonna have as much luck the person
who was the successful bidder on this
Banksy piece lucked out not only did she
get the bang seat but she got the Banksy
she got the you know the media hype
around her piece it's definitely gonna
sell for more down the line and I think
that when it's hanging in her wall and
someone walks in they'll know exactly
what it is whenever that painting
resurfaces again it's going to be an
exciting moment
[Music]